in his long career as an obstetrician  and gynecologist dr. Jack Soler  delivered more than 3,000 babies if I  could count the number of people in the  Jackie Zoeller fan club it would take a  while said his son Gary he was pure and  not judgmental and gave that to everyone  as a gift a lifelong New Orlean  doctor Zoeller graduated Tulane and LSU  Medical School he married Linda Malkin  and together they raised four kids  before she died of cancer in 1994 at his  second home in Telluride Colorado doctor  Zoeller loved to fish and volunteered at  the Telluride Film Festival  he spent his last year's in Lambeth  House retirement community in New  Orleans last month he became the center  of the city's deadliest coronavirus  cluster he was the prince at Lambeth  house carries over said if you knew him  you loved him dr. Jack Soler who was 91  [Music]